[Musique]
ce pays des antilles a été secoué par
très forts tremblements de terre on
apprend ce matin que d'autres villes que
port-au-prince ont été détruites chaque
seconde compte là plus le temps avance
plus les chances à minuit c'est pourquoi
les secouristes redoublaient vraiment
d'effort il faut se préparer au pire
dans mon partage
deep mathur épais comme ça avec une
couverture est trop chaud on tient à
connaître les gens qui ont conduit à la
publication des secrets de guerre publié
dans le site internet wikileaks parce
que pour washington divulguer des
informations qui auraient dû rester
confidentielles et bien cela comporte
des risques
autant d'informations privilégiées qui
ne mettent toutefois personne en danger
un féru son fondateur alors que les
wagons de métro était littéralement
bondés de voyageurs
une femme kamikaze s'est fait exploser
quarante minutes plus tard sur la même
ligne une autre femme kamikaze
une autre explosion dans une station
très achalandé ça ressemble à un
attentat tchétchènes ou un attentat de
rebelles du nord caucase
et ce soir ça culmine avec le meurtre de
nick rizzuto et taux de résolution des
crimes par la police zéro jusqu'à
présent le beaucoup beaucoup d'agitation
les cafés italiens les pizzerias des
usines
est ce que tout ça est relié du seul à
dire c'est terrible tragédie qui a coûté
la vie aujourd'hui au président de la
pologne lech kaczinsky et sa femme maria
a aussi décapité une bonne partie des
élites politiques polonaises 33 mineurs
chiliens prise au piège depuis deux mois
ont tous été ramenés à la surface
on était assez confiants dans la
fiabilité du matériel pour se rendre
compte que tout fonctionnait bien
qui aurait cru que le frère andré allait
devenir le premier a mené au québec à
devenir un saint
[Musique]
le canada avec trois médailles de plus
et c'est pas fini pour la soirée
probablement ce qui serait un record là
tous jeux confondus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]